all right hello everybody I'm here with
Seth caustic Alan sake and on audio and
Seth caustic was a speaker at the
science and non-duality conference which
we were just at recently and he gets
into all kinds of badassery around
physics quantum mechanics and
metaphysics and stuff like that and Alan
following this is gonna dive into that
with him however right now
we are here together to explore well
thank you for having the ORAC so I'm
ready to explore with you why because
it's a fun game to play really oh yeah
you really think it's fun that's nice oh
yeah
I mentioned game a lot and there are
serious games and trivial games and
sincere games and everything in between
so I don't mean triviality exclusively
and I don't mean that this is
necessarily serious but a game is the
definition of a game is something
engaged as a diversion or for amusement
so this is a game because I'm diverting
my attention for myself to play with you
here great well I'm listening man yeah
and I'm listening to you
so I love talking about science and
non-duality it was great to see you at
the conference and for people that don't
know science and non-duality us is a
fantastic
event and you'll meet all kinds of great
people there and you can just saw
science and non-duality and how the mind
works and it was a fantastic experience
I really blessed for having not only
just to go but I was really grateful for
being able to be a presenter there
because it allows you to engage with
people in a whole nother level so I'm
thankful for that it's a great yes I had
an incredible experience as well yeah
and I was curious about who some of your
favorite speakers were because I'm
always looking for new and different
perspectives on this apparent reality
man the quote-unquote heavyweights like
addy Ashanti and Rupert Spira
that were in the main ballroom with like
hundreds or thousands of people was
really cool to be with and explore Who I
am
yeah and so that was epic you know Rick
Archer who has like the show Buddha had
the cast I didn't see him there was he
there he was okay I didn't see him
because I thought he would have a I
thought he would have a setup like this
there and then I didn't see him I think
he did that before right he had a video
years back there I think he was doing
video that's right with like a bunch of
spit yeah
and so I didn't I didn't see anything
like that but and I didn't think he was
there but you know it's so it's actually
sees very large and there are so many
talks going on simultaneously that it's
impossible to take it all and you're
gonna have to go like three or four
years in a row to see some of the depth
and breadth that they they have there so
Zion Mauricio do an amazing job and all
the volunteers and all the staff and
everyone that puts their their best
efforts into so you make it a
spectacular experience so that that I
just really appreciate all that so
was really great and it's great to see
you there thanks man I'm I'm still
processing the whole thing I think many
people are I don't think people
understand for those people who don't
know about sand the science and
non-duality conference I don't think
they understand that the magnitude or
the gravity of it and they go there and
then after you need like a week to
process all that information
you just can't it's just overwhelming
I'm shocked that actually more people
don't just leave the conference early
because it's just so much there it's
just so hard to take in everything so it
took me a good week I'd say I'm still
processing stuff today like things is it
will rock your world
it really will rock your world so I
highly recommend it
beautiful yeah so we're here and I guess
we're like wine and stuff you don't
guess you're knowing that you're one
you're knowing that way because
everyone's showing up ever since science
and non-duality and it's like they know
everything about me yeah so the thing
about non-duality and i don't know what
background the audience has with this
but non-duality is an artful way of
saying that all is one without using the
word one because one implies not one or
many and although not one or non-duality
is also a dualistic terms it is trying
the language it's trying to go out of
its way to say one so that you try to
break the habit of the mind of thinking
in terms of opposites so non-duality
saying all is one well what is this one
that we're all what is it
and the only being here
is the knowing that is knowing
experience so this knowing is being
because if it wasn't being there would
be nothing for it to know so it's a
fusion of knowing being and since it's
all this here it's infinite because
anything that would be other than it
would limited so it's this all-pervading
unity of consciousness that's what
consciousness is it's knowing me and
since it's infinite it has no edge to it
or handles or surface to it it's not
limited to any dimensionality
so it's dimensionless it's no wing so
it's always in the now there's no time
for it it's eternal so it's I come from
a point my point of view comes from
physics I did not arrive at this
conclusion from any sort of spiritual or
religious practices it's non duality is
not a religion so when you come from it
from this physics perspective the
closest you can get to a dimensionless
being is what we term a singularity so
the mathematics that I use to describe
this arises from black hole
thermodynamic entropy from the
bekenstein Hawking equations describing
a conceptual singularities geometric
information content so this is how I
approach it but we're all describing the
same thing these mystics writing about
non duality and advaita there in the
physicists describing this apparent
experience or occurrence or knowing
being there just talking about the same
being that all that's here is an
infinite dimensionless knowing being
singular consciousness and you're it who
me not you
or II or YZ occurring inside of that
consciousness as the illusion of
something other than that consciousness
you're not Ori though you could change
your name tomorrow right but you'd still
be you right right yeah so okay you're
not Ori the name okay so you have an
image of your body are you an image
close your eyes close your eyes I mean
all right close her up when you close
your eyes you blink you just blinked so
did you disappear the image went away
but you didn't so you could change your
gender you could change the history of
your little story you've got about
yourself all of those change but you
remain constant you remain the knowing
of that content the knowing of images
the knowing of sounds the knowing of
your thoughts because that's all this
here there's nothing other than infinite
consciousness here so that's who you
really are
but you've identified you've played some
identity politics with yourself and
you've identified with Ori and you can
only identify with Ori by knowing what
Ori is not so Ori is not this plant or
ease not this microphone or it's not the
cameras over there this is already okay
so your your your knowing these
opposites and identifying with one part
of it ignoring the rest of yourself
and just playing this little game
created me who created you consciousness
or you or your parents created Ori
consciousness would never began or never
ends its a singularity it's always in
the now it's always been here forever
and ever never there is no time for it
because if you're a singularity and you
have no dimensions there's no time
because without space there's no time
space and time are fused into space-time
what's moving your actions what's your
motivation my motivation for doing this
work yeah well I have several so one I
find I went into science because I
actually just find science fascinating
like it's super fun too if you don't
have never been up to the ALS at
Berkeley and played with the beamline
or play with you know high powered
electron microscopes and all the tools
and toys I just telling you before we
start here look at all this gear you
guys got you got a great set up here
I love the gear like I love playing with
that kind of stuff so that's just super
fun but additionally when you when
you're kind of starting off on this
little adventure of life here you don't
know what any of this is right you just
hear statements and you accept them as
true that's the definition of belief so
somebody tells you that this is a world
and you say yeah I agree this is a world
that's a belief it's a statement that
you accept it right we need people who
can navigate belief lessness that's all
that's here but you're ignoring them
there's only knowing here
not believing knowing is knowing beliefs
to fool itself that it's a human being
we think we're having this little
conversation here no there's only
consciousness here it's the illusion of
a conversation we're ignoring the
infinite nests
to know the illusion of flying I heard
about and accepted that this is a
microphone I believe it it's a lie
I accept that lie and I live this little
life so when you are look at this
collection of beliefs that you've held
and then you're like well how does this
really work and you're really curious
about it you've got you know three main
modes of epistemology you can justify
these beliefs with belief which is
religion you could justify these beliefs
with do you logic like I'm behind in
realizing all this stuff no there's no
behind this is what you're doing you see
this is what you're doing you're doing
this on purpose you're knowing you're
all going so this is what you want to
know you want to know overcoming your
own ignorance are you doing a great job
so
should I be embarrassed if that's what
you want to know there's no reason for
embarrassment other than to know what
that feels like cuz you're already
perfect you be embarrassed should there
are no shoulds I've been embarrassed but
not about trying to find out who I am
it's funny when you see that you've
taken this game very seriously and
you've done things that but I mean
people are watching we're creating a
video that's gonna go into the world and
we're creating our futures there's
something at stake yeah and the
importance that you've assigned to that
is what you're doing you're saying that
this is very important and so it is
should I should you what should I be
careful well with great power comes
great responsibility
so if you realize what you really are
this infinite knowing being of
consciousness then you should be with
care because you're knowing you can know
anything you will get what you want so
you should have some care to make sure
you know what you're doing mm-hmm when
you don't know what you're doing
you get pollution you get terrible
travis's but that's just cuz you're
asleep at the wheel you didn't know what
you're doing it's just part of your
being your infinite so all occurrences
occurring
even the bad stuff but you don't have to
determine that bad stuff as in I'll tell
you what I want what do you want the
best you got it cuz you already yet see
you're already the best there's no one
so you two have something that's not the
best they're happy something other than
infinite consciousness so you guys want
to play in the playground in the mud
with the playmates and see third see
through the best unfoldment while
knowing the freedom that the freedom of
the meaninglessness that you speak of
you'll have that if that's really what
you want to know you're starting on it
right we're playing here right we're
little playmates here today so you're
starting on that journey you're doing it
you've limited yourself so you're not
doing it all at one time you've limited
yourself to the concept of time so it
has to unfold and this chaos at the end
of time here is this unfolding so you're
doing it you're getting your wish great
how about you oh I'm playing so many
games at the same time so this is
delicious
there's nothing more delicious than
falling asleep ignoring what all this is
thinking you're a little human being and
getting lost and having a job getting
rejected by your girlfriend losing your
house and oh this thing caught on fire
and ho now you're bankrupt and you're
awful if you're lost and then suddenly
awaking from that and realize that the
whole thing that all that all that stuff
was an illusion
it was you the whole time the contrast
from those different this was not even a
perspective so the contrast there is
just so delicious it is the most
magnificent thing you can experience
this is why we do this trust me you're
ignoring your infinite is on purpose
because you're all-knowing you already
know everything you're all perfection so
there's nothing to do
you're perfect they're already all it so
to have the struggles of life is the
meaning of life is to know what it's
like to be limited if you're unlimited
that's what they say yeah you want to
know what it's like to be limited well
being limited when you're actually an
unlimited being you're unlimited but
then now you're bumping against all
these limits that's what suffering is
you're really infinite but now you're
knowing what limitation really is and it
hurts because you sure I'm really
infinite here but you know when I run up
a hill and I have an exercise in a long
time
my legs are on fire because I'm
experience experiencing the pain of
limitation
it's thrilling for this infinite being
to do this there's something amazing
about overcoming the obstacles in life
so if you want to mow down all obstacles
can flatten the illusion of this
hierarchy here and have everyone be
exactly the same there will be no
obstacles to overcome it'll be nothing
to do and it leave very boring so if you
celebrate the differences understand
that yeah we're all different and there
are these hierarchies and there are this
is the way the game is set up and people
different perspectives overcoming
different obstacles creates a beautiful
game but yet there's a unity we're all
related by one being our consciousness
no matter how different you are or how
different I am different genders race
anything we're unified by our knowing
there is only one knowing here and it's
shared between all of us so this is what
you know the Constitution the Bill of
Rights this is what that's getting it
we're all created equal because we're
all this knowing this knowing is knowing
different limitations for each apparent
perspective so are we physically equal
no but actually equal yes and so when
you see this and you you you see this
through the physics the act the physics
of are derived from doing experiments
within experience the truth of
experience this truth of knowing what is
occurring this truth of knowing what is
occurring which is the being of
consciousness by science going to that
experience and getting its using it as
its arbiter
and then you see that that physics is
telling you that everything is a unity a
singularity of consciousness
well that's huge because then now you
can contextualize all the content that
you thought was physical and material
outside of consciousness you can
contextualize it as consciousness so you
can still have your differences
you can still see each other as human
beings but conceptually understand that
everybody is this unity and then now how
are you gonna treat people if I walk
into a store and I see you there and
you've got something I want am I gonna
just steal it from you no because I know
that you are you're me so we're gonna
treat each other the physics that's
pointing to the actuality is gonna allow
us to conceptually understand when
embraces you there all this yeah I feel
like oh like a wide-eyed kid or
something yeah so the thing to make sure
you understand is that you can't believe
me belief is a lie if you accept the
statements that I tell you you trap
yourself in this labyrinth of your own
mind so what you have to do is know this
for yourself and this is what the
techniques of meditation etc it's self
inquiry this is what this is for so when
you know then you really get it and then
you understand that the you can't
actually get it there's nothing to get
the the being that you're trying to get
is an infinite being so there's no edge
to it you can't grasp it with the mind
it's what's making the mind but dude I
got work to do in this world do you I
don't know if people need to be seeing
me appear in like a wide-eyed kid here
with Seth kostik giving me the the
briefing you can do whatever you want
you don't have to do anything you can
forget all this if you want you can
investigate it further
but again if you believe these
statements you're not going to be able
to embody them because you have to know
you can't believe and that's why science
is so powerful science comes from the
Latin science which means knowing to
know or ask a witch from the
proto-indo-european root that means to
cut so this is knowing appears to cut
its own being into complementary
opposites which then we ignore the
infinite opposite and focus on the
illusion of these limits but they're
solely made out of knowing there's
nothing but knowing there so knowing is
your the authority on that no
consciousness is the only authority it's
the author
it's the creator it's all that's here
you are that author you want to write
them if you want to write the book that
says I'm not the authority I give my
authority away you can write that story
well I mean I like right in the book
that says I am the authority and that's
why I want to be the authority you
already are
there's nothing you can do to be it are
you sure yeah there was a great talk I'm
gonna butcher his name who was Swamy
Sara I can't remember that Sara I'd have
to look it up but there was a fellow I
think he teaches at Harvard yeah he was
at sand and he he said all religious
practices or again it's not really a
religion but Buddhist practices when
people come into the ashram and they say
yeah I wanna I wanna I want to wake up I
want to find out who I really am right
so they say well you already are this
and then the person says no that's
impossible I want to be it show me how
to be it set okay
so you're already in the ashram you're
already this infinite being so if we
call the Astra on this being and you're
already in it giving up on playing in
the sandbox no but where would you have
to go if you already in in this ashram
as this infinite being where would you
have to go to get there nowhere you're
already there
so what these gurus they what they do is
they tell you okay okay you're already
here you don't see that you're already
here so they send you on a little
journey okay okay take a left walk down
the street go up the hill walk around go
to the playground play around there then
go to the store grab me a carton of milk
and then come back here and this is will
you'll find your own being then you're
sitting in the ashram again after I've
counting on this long journey all around
the world looking for yourself and you
come back and you're like oh I was there
the whole time I didn't need to walk out
the door and if I was already there so
it's a good little story is that that's
all these little techniques are so
meditation that's just the little
journey to find out that you were
already at this whole thing self inquiry
is this little journey you take to find
out that you were you were consciousness
you already figured this out I so you as
in Seth no Seth is not conscious isn't
just content there's no so consciousness
is the only being that is knowing the
content here of Seth that appears to
have figured it's up or woken they say
awakened but this right here this is
asleep this is very sleepy this is not
woke there's no Seth has no intelligence
at all the intelligence is consciousness
there is only consciousness is the only
being that's intelligent rocks are not
conscious as tree is not conscious
it's made of consciousness occurring in
consciousness and is known by consoles
why
don't doesn't this one identify as that
one oh because when you wake up then you
it's so shocking like you it you you go
awakened and you I don't I mean I don't
know I really don't have that much I
don't really study Eastern religion or
philosophy so I don't really know about
the Buddha that much but I'm from my own
personal experience like you you can't
just one boom you're awake you're done
it's over like now I don't I don't know
how that's possible so for me it's like
no you have these like successive
awakenings where it happens you don't
know what the heck happened yeah it's
just total shock and you don't even you
don't even know what's going on and then
it happens again and again and again and
again and then it just starts transform
you just start transforming your then
why do I feel this realization when I'm
around you who's there who's feeling it
you're knowing not feeling it if you
don't feel it you're knowing that on
purpose as consciousness you're saying
I'll know this content over here that
looks like a set that's knowing this and
I'll know this content over here that's
worried that's not knowing it now how
many of these awakenings were sober and
how many were assisted with drugs well
what do you mean by a drug because if I
eat a banana
there's molecules in there so there's
mommy you eat a salad there's all kinds
of tryptamines and things in there so
what do you really mean by a drug let's
see that this is a definition that is
crazy
you've got drug stores and drug wars so
you can buy drugs but then you can't buy
other ones so I don't really know you
know does that make your heart feel oh
it's part of the game it's a perfection
it has to be
way if everyone was doing psychedelics
all together the everybody to be awake
so you can't have that they got to be
illegal otherwise there'd be no game
people wouldn't ignore what who they
really are and then everybody would just
be infinite consciousness people
wouldn't ignore who they really are and
that's a poor way of saying it so
consciousness wouldn't be able to ignore
its infiniteness just that aspect yeah
I'm just saying if you if you smoked
like five Meo DMT every day for fifty
days or something I'm sure you wake up I
don't know I've never done it so but I'm
it's pretty powerful stuff so yeah as
the author you have to make this illegal
because there would be no game and you
want the game I mean I want someone to
make me an iPhone iPhones are fun yeah
without people doing that there would be
no iPhones so who's a better spiritual
guy me or you the only one that could
awaken is you consciousness so me who's
the author consciousness if you're
saying I'm consciousness then yes you if
you're saying I or II there's no or II
is just content it's just an image
thoughts feelings smells there's there's
nothing to an Ori
other than the story and the content
you're made out of knowing complementary
opposites that interfere with each other
to produce this interference pattern
that I'm looking at and I'm taking that
to be an Ori but there's not an orator
does the illusion of an orator what I'm
looking at is consciousness who creates
it consciousness
what about identity so when you say are
you I mean are you conscious mm-hmm so
you say I am conscious I knowing knowing
is what I is and is to be so knowing
being consciousness knowing so your
identity is knowing being knowing that
phrase I am conscious simultaneously
means two things it means I am aware of
the illusion of these things these
occurrences and this is my identity who
are you I am conscious my identity my I
am miss is consciousness what if as you
share I have a hard time staying with
the concepts and feel like zoning out
from what you're saying yeah it's so the
issue with the language that I'm using
is that you have this little game here
of abstracting things into opposites so
that you can know the illusion of these
things you couldn't know them if it was
just if you were just paying attention
to infinite consciousness there would be
no difference between anything so we
just all be one unity here that's all
that is really here but you're ignoring
that so now when I say the word knowing
there's the absolute actual infinite
knowing and there's the concept of
knowing not equals knowing but now if I
say if I'm telling talking to you and
I'm talking about the concept of knowing
versus right the actual knowing you
don't know what you want to talk about
so now you're like oh he's going between
the actual the conceptual and then I
don't know if he's referring to concepts
or
limits or to infinite knowing and so
when I write I have in my own special
punctuation or a little linguistic
system that I used just some symbols
that distinguish the actual from the
conceptual so again this is a conceptual
distinguishment the actual knowing that
I'm right it's still conceptual because
if you can grasp it it's it's but I'm
ignoring that and just saying when I use
capital letters I'm referring to an
infinite actuality with no complimentary
opposite and then these actual title
case terms are synonymous so if I say
knowing with the credit okay yeah if I
say knowing with a capital K that's the
same as being with the capital B that's
the same as truth with a capital T
that's the same as experience with a
capital e so like truth with a capital T
is infinite it's all there is the
concept of true not equals true or the
entangled concept of true false
that's conceptual that's relative it's
only true that you are there and I am
here in this relativistic space-time
continuum how does that work okay so in
order to have something appear finite
you have to know the illusion of
limitation so I have to take infinite
consciousness and abstract it into these
opponents mm-hm
so I only know what this is by knowing
that it's not not equals this this never
occurs by itself it's literally made of
knowing knowing the cycle of abstraction
of knowing that this is not not equals
this okay so these always arises pairs
and this is what is called duality
you're in duality the two this is the
two so non duality is the realization
that these two apparent opposites solely
made out of infinite know
is that they're really just made out of
knowing that's what Nandu Elias so
they're it's really the knowing that's
known in these offices so how this stuff
is created is that knowing has to
abstract its being into these compliment
jobs and how deep is your trust in these
ideas well the ideas are just this is a
game this is these are ideas so you can
live your life by them if you want to or
you can transcend all of it did this the
the things I'm saying are conceptually
true and will only be conceptually true
in the new paradigm once you go black
you never come back I think once you
wake up it's hard to see the world in
any other way like you don't you it's
the same it's the same world apples to
this stuff the illusion of levels yeah
if they look like levels they look like
yeah like any video game right has
different levels right you're just going
through but it's all one game so just
just so you know like when you wake like
know you this all looks the same
you're looking straight at infinite
being here it's just that yeah but you
know it but your body is just like
saying that to me and it's like you're
just like sharing that and I'm like if
you like really open to this idea but
all I see is a guy here yeah so that's
because and I see this a lot with even
at the non-dual conference is that
people want to turn non-duality into a
religion they want to believe that it's
the case so they have to give up their
beliefs see your beliefs are what's
gonna prevent you from understanding so
you have to do you have to know you have
to use experience
you can't just accept things that the
speakers at sand or anyone tells you
it's an experience it's knowing it
cannot be a complimentary opposite you
think you cannot know the concept you
can't conceptualize your way to it you
you can't go through the mind the mind
is the knowing of these opposites it's
it's precisely the mind that is keeping
you from understanding the infinite
totality it's the activity of ignoring
the infinite totality so you so you have
to give up that activity of knowing
opposites once you give up that activity
of knowing opposites there's only you
here infinite being so I guess when you
wake you you you can do both right you
can know the opposites and know the
infinite totality simultaneously so it's
this like amazing yeah you can have
these opposites and know that it's all
one infinite consciousness it's shocking
it's not what you think it is in fact if
you can think it is not it if you can
grasp what you you're like oh I know I
know it's gonna be like this you don't
got it because it you can't because you
need the mind to know the illusion of
these opposites so once you transcend
that I don't know how I don't know how
you even know how to describe it
I can't even it's impossible but it's
possible you can do it you can be it
just like you know I've got this tip of
this finger right can I touch the tip of
this finger with the tip of this finger
no it's impossible
the tip of this finger is the tip of
this finger so I can't use it to touch
it so if I want to experience touch I
have to touch something else I have to
have to I have to have duality right
okay but now if I want to be this tip of
this finger it already is it it you're
it's it it done it's it was it the whole
time it never wasn't it it was always
the tip of this finger
so if we plays finger and we call this
consciousness or knowing if knowing
wants to know something finite it's got
to know something else it's got a limit
it's infinite being to know the illusion
of something else
but to be consciousness it already is
consciousness he was conscious as the
whole time but can consciousness know
itself as an object no it needs the
illusion of something else
so it's topologically bound it is the
thing or it's not a thing sorry it is
the being that's here and it's infinite
so there's nothing outside of it you
can't like hold up a mirror and shine it
back on itself it can't because that
mirror would also be it so it can never
get outside of itself to know itself the
only way to do it is to appear to divide
itself and then interfere these concepts
together to give you the illusion of
objectivity now this thing can know the
illusion of these objects because it's
make these objects kind of arise out of
the ignorance of its infinite news
they're like sculpted out of it like a
sculptor removes stone to reveal the
marble inside if you have one brick a
marble it's just an infinite being there
but you chip away the marble you remove
or appear to remove what consciousness
appear to obvious get a period yeah
ignore it and then the statue appears
same thing you're carving this out of
your own infinite being through the mind
there's only consciousness this
consciousness knows the mind and then
the mind produces the illusion of
objects we got it backwards we think
that there's a physical material world
here physical material world evolved
beings that then evolved consciousness
the exact opposite the exact opposite
you're occurring in consciousness
space-time occurs in consciousness
so it's easy to see that all the content
within experience is made out of knowing
these relative opposites because this is
what relativity is mm-hmm
mass time distance all changes with
relativistic motion it's not confident
what is constant the knowing of that
content the speed of light the knowing
of the content is what we term the speed
of light and that's absolute it's the
same for every perspective there's only
one speed of light or one getting of an
information rate the getting of
information I you know I got a book here
it's close I don't have information I
read the book I get the information
that's knowing right so if there's a
light over there a light minute away
they turn it on I don't see it in a
minute
the light enter speeds into my eyes and
now I'm knowing it so the speeding of
that information into my eyes the rate
that's knowing that's what knowing is
there's only one that's the speed of
light same for every reference frame so
now we know there's only one
consciousness it's in our physics it's
right there it's obvious I decided was
so close because he basically created
quantum physics and relativity together
all like couple years you know he took
what Planck I mean he I mean he started
and it basically it's it's quantum
mechanics he won the Nobel Prize for the
photoelectric effect so the the he was
right on it
and was he a great mathematician no he's
horrible at math but did he have an
imagination oh yeah and the only
imagination the only being that's making
these images is consciousness so he was
tapped in
that's why he could do what he did
because it's not about the math although
the math helps convince or construct
limits that allow us to manipulate the
illusion of this content and if you can
manipulate the illusion of this content
you are like a magician right
scientists are your magicians I mean
your iPhone is magical this is an
unbelievable thing be grateful for the
technology and the tools you have there
wielding true magic now I think magic is
like sums you know supernatural or
mysterious for us right why is it
mysterious because to the illusion of
something finite cannot know the
infinite it's the infinite always
remains a mystery to our finite or the
illusion of our finite perspectives so
it's magical this consciousness it's
magical to us because it's a mystery
because I can't know it as an object so
by doing science doing the math you can
then limit consciousness in different
ways and you can really play now we
haven't begun to play with quantum
mechanics iPhones this is nothing once
we expand the mathematics and really
understand what we're doing well then
you got to be careful because with great
power comes great responsibility we've
already seen the horrors that we
unleashed on this world with
thermonuclear nuclear weapons this is
nothing that's child's play what you're
going to be able to do with a
mathematics of conscious singularity is
off the scale
so got to be careful
or not do whatever you want but from my
point of view challenges are great but
undue suffering right there's not need
for undue suffering it seems like you
know it's great to have challenges but
we taking it too far I think so I think
the universe is coming back to its a
more equitable and fun game for
everybody that's what we're doing we're
in this time of change as Michael Mead
pointed out we're in this right of
passage
there's something happening here right
it's this paradigm shift from physical
materialism to conscious singularity
this is what we're doing we're gonna
shift the way we contextualize our
experience into a more holistic or
evolved state of being
thank you well thank you this is a great
conversation you're way better at
basketball than I am by the way
I think we can wrap up on that baby well
thank you very much for having me on
your well this was a treat it really is
I love to talk about this so thank you
Thank You Alan for being the doing the
work beyond the scenes and being on
audio yeah Thank You Alan
you guys are so welcome great
conversation thanks to our viewers for
watching and we'll see you soon